thank you mayor Cooper again thank you
all for being here just an update from
today's press conference
we've identified the shooter as Audrey
Hale uh 28 year old female that lived in
the Nashville area
we have
investigations ongoing now at the
residence on Brightwood Avenue
and we have made contact with the father
that lived at that residence and are
putting together more information
information
we've also determined there were Maps
drawn of the school in detail of
surveillance entry points Etc
we know and believe that entry was
gained through shooting through one of
the doors is how they actually got into
the school
I wanna take the time to at least say
and I won't say the victims names I let
Don say that but out of the six victims
three adults
three of those were children two of them
were age nine
one was eight about to be nine
all the families have been contacted
the victims families have been contacted
as well my thoughts and prayers go out
to the family when we send our kids to
school or to any place of safety we
expect them to live learn have fun and
come back
from that day day's experience we don't
anticipate things like this
and I want to say thank you to our
partners
to Chief Swan
to Glen Funk to our mayor for his
support to our federal partners
but also I want to say thank you to our
First Responders who got there
and immediately went in and addressed
the threat of someone that had multiple
rounds of ammunition
prepared for a confrontation with law
enforcement prepared to do more harm
that was actually done and we were able
to stop the threat and unfortunately six
victims so my thoughts and prayers again
but the praise go to the men and women
as I've said before
we will not wait I was hoping this day
would never ever come here in this city
but we would never wait
to make entry and to go in and to stop a
threat especially when it deals with our
children
so thank you
it's just me they're not say anything
I'm going to go over the victims names
with you now
the three nine-year-olds
who were killed Evelyn
dick house
William Kenny
Hallie Scruggs
three adults
Mike Hill
a custodian age 61.
Cynthia Peake to my understanding a
substitute teacher age 61
and Catherine Coots
age 60.
as Chief Drake said we have identified
the active shooter is Audrey Elizabeth
Hale
age 28.
we'll take just a few questions if you
have any Don do you believe that she was
a former student at the school
yes we do chief you want to address that
yes from our investigations tell us that
she was a former student at the school I
don't know what grade she's attended or
grades but we do affirmly believe she
was the student there
she does uh I didn't identify as
transgender yes is there any reason to
believe juder first went to the church
before going to the school
uh I can't give you that information I
want should we know that the minute the
calls came in we responded uh to the
church so to the school yeah okay
so it was five officers that immediately
went in and addressed uh we have video
that we're going to release but you can
see in the video you can hear gunfire
going on as they're in the school they
address the threat and take that threat
down and see what do we know about her
weapons
so we know there were two AR style
weapons one a rifle another was an AR
style pistol and another was a handgun
We Believe two of those may have been
obtained legally locally here
confirmed that one of the adult victims
Catherine kinsky sent to school was what
there was some I don't know her exact
capacity within the school but it was
power up in echelon
unsure I believe one may have been but I
can't confirm that
no history at all
and no motive at this point uh anything
discovered in the apartment or the house
no we have a Manifesto we have some
writings that we're going over that
pertain to this day the actual incident
we have a map drawn out of how this was
all going to take place there's right
now a theory of that's that we may be
able to talk about later but it's not
confirmed and so we'll we'll put that
out as soon as we can is there any
reason to
I'm sorry I knocked someone's Michael I
didn't hear you say that again sir
to believe how she identifies is has any
motive for targeting the school
uh we can give you that at a later time
there is uh some Theory to that we're
investigating all the leads and once we
know exactly we will let you know
it was
don't know any history of mental illness
at this time but we are looking at that
as an investigation is ongoing and I'm
sorry
as a friend or woman a woman
it was the only school that was targeted
there was another location that was
mentioned but because of a threat
assessment by the suspect of too much
security they decided not to and that
area was here in Nashville so we're
continuing with that investigation as
well right now we believe it's a loan
assailant and we don't anticipate any
further damage at this time but we're
still investigating
looking thank you
so the scene is going to be processed
throughout the night probably into
tomorrow
this is an extensive scene as you know
she entered the building which is one
structure the church and the school are
in one building she entered on the lower
floor there were shops fired on the
lower floor before she went to the upper
level and it was on the upper level
where she was confronted by police and
killed
so understand the scene processing will
take place over at least
two days today and tomorrow
and we'll have more details for you
including the release of video uh
perhaps tonight but if not tonight
certainly tomorrow
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the way that I
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now